Brian we tagged along with an HVAC
technician to get a look at their
workload we also spoke to Residents to
see how they're managing their AC as the
temperatures rise
usually every other year it's a it's a
new episode It's A New Journey something
always happens so I expect the worse
Terence blygen says when it comes to air
conditioning it's been nothing but bad
luck so I have an appointment next week
for them to check up on the upkeep
yo just in case if something does happen
you know we want to make sure that
everything's okay and although we're
getting a later start to warmer weather
this year HVAC companies have been
keeping busy
Bumble Breeze technician Omar Martinez
explains as of right now we're getting a
lot of Maintenance costs so I think
people are seeing how hot it's starting
to get and they just want to get ready
right before summer really hits us
Martinez says people will often turn off
their AC when they are away but what
that's doing is making the ACU twice as
hard when you turn it back on
so it's best to just increase the
temperature when you're away and lower
it when you return home we definitely
keep it at a certain setting during the
day when we're not home obviously we
can't let it get too hot because we do
have animals another common mistake
Martinez sees people not changing their
filters every two months those filters I
mean you can think of it like your veins
you know if it's clogged up just like a
clogged vein it's going to affect the
arteries and it's just going to affect
the whole system
Tech say it's best to keep your room
temp at about 74 degrees and don't
forget the lower you set your
temperature the harder the unit is going
to work thus the higher your energy bill
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now